in nur 45 tagen zum mars reisen genau
das könnte schon bald möglich sein denn
ein kanadisches forschungsteam hat jetzt
die idee für einen antrieb entwickelt
mit dem wir bereits in anderthalb stadt
bis zu neun monaten auf den roten
planeten gelangen könnten möglich machen
soll das ein laser optik der raumschiffe
mit bis zu 60.000 kilometern pro stunde
zum mars katapultiert klick zum science
im future gibt zwei mal pro woche sparen
das heißt dass abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen mehr als ein halbes
jahr sieben bis neun monate dauert
derzeit eine reise zum roten planeten
dabei wollen alle gerade genau das eine
bemannte weltraummissionen zum roten
planeten nicht nur die
us-weltraumbehörde nasa sondern auch die
chinesischen raum ferne cms und
natürlich in masken mit seinem space ex
programm und genau dabei könnte ihnen
jetzt die idee eines innovative
antriebskonzept vom kanadischen forschen
sehr entgegenkommen denn damit könnte
die reise zum mars deutlich kürzer
werden menschen und nutzlast könnten
damit nämlich lediglich 45 tagen also
anderthalb monaten den roten planeten
erreichen dafür müssen gigantisch große
leser gebaut werden die in der lage sind
raumschiffen von der erde aus in
richtung mars zu katapultieren doch wie
genau soll das funktionieren und wie
realistisch sind diese pläne wirklich
die antworten auf all diese spannenden
fragen und noch viel mehr wie immer gibt
es jetzt hier von mir die idee des
kanadischen forschungsteams ist eine
antwort auf eine art ideenwettbewerb der
nasa denn bereits seit vier jahren also
seit 2008 zehn sucht man hier nach
möglichkeiten um schnellere flüge zum
mars zu realisieren denn das hätte ganz
klare vorteile eine deutlich kürzere
reisezeit würde sowohl den menschen an
bord des raumschiffes als auch der
nutzlast an bord zu gute kommen die
schädliche kosmische strahlung würde
dann deutlich kürzer in kauf genommen
werden das laserstrahlen uns dabei
helfen könnten raumschiffe von der erde
aus anzutreiben das ist keine neue idee
bereits seit jahren sind forschende
weltweit dabei entsprechende konzepte zu
entwickeln kleine sonden könnten dafür
mit gigantisch großen sonnensegel extrem
beschleunigt werden konkret denken
fachleute beispielsweise darüber nach
mit der hilfe von lasern das proxima
system zu erreichen bereits vor sechs
jahren 2016 hatte der us physiker viele
blogger vorgeschlagen sondern mithilfe
gigantischer sonnensegel so stark zu
beschleunigen dass die interstellare
entfernung in überschaubarer zeit
überbrücken können laut lipper könnte
ein segel mit einem durchmesser von
einem meter von einem leser mit 50 bis
70 gigawatt leistung innerhalb von zehn
minuten achtung auf 26 prozent der
lichtgeschwindigkeit beschleunigt werden
das ist wahnsinnig schnell wenn diese
idee tatsächlich eines tages in die
praxis umgesetzt werden könnte wäre das
genial den mars könnten wir so in nur 30
minuten erreichen und einfach centauri
in nur 15 jahren doch bis dahin sind
noch einige herausforderungen zu
meistern benötigt werden nicht nur
dünnere materialien für die sonden
sondern auch eine deutlich bessere
leistungsfähigkeit der längst auch das
projekt break star schott widmet sich
dieser vision mit dabei unter anderem
die harvard physiker wie loeb und der
russische milliardär yuri milner
dutzende mini raumschiffe können demnach
an riesigen licht segeln in richtung
alpha centauri geschickt werden dabei
eingesetzt würde ein laser auf der erde
der seinen impuls auf ein nur wenige
gramm schwere sonnensegel gibt die mini
sonden könnten dabei auf die extrem hohe
geschwindigkeit von etwa 20 prozent der
lichtgeschwindigkeit beschleunigt werden
und das muss man sich mal vorstellen
trotz dieser hohen beschleunigung würde
solch eine reise zu unserem nachbar
sonnensystem bei diesem projekt wohl
mehr als zwanzig jahre dauert übrigens
wurden tests sondern für dieses projekt
bereits in den erdgeschichte und kreisen
auf unserem planeten zwei deutsche
wissenschaftler hatten ergänzend dazu
dann eine idee entwickelt wie solche
weltraum sondern nicht nur in kurzer
zeit unseren nachbarstädten alpha
centauri erreichen können sondern dort
dann auch abbremsen können das ist eine
riesenherausforderung
das war bislang nämlich wirklich einfach
möglich jedenfalls theoretisch nicht
möglich dank der strahlung des sterns
könnte sie vor ort auch abbremsen und
dort im system bleiben so könnten sie
dann sogar zu proxima centauri und den
exoplaneten gelenkt werden so der plan
der beiden max planck forscher jetzt
haben kanadische wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler ein neues
antriebskonzept entwickelt das
raumfahrtmissionen deutlich schneller
machen könnte sie haben sich von den
bereits bestehenden ideen zum laser
antrieb inspirieren lassen dazu sagt
einer der beteiligten forscher ein
manuell uplay in einem interview mit der
website university day die ultimative
anwendung des laser antriebs für
interstellare reisen hatte unser team
motiviert diese studie durchzuführen
wir waren daran interessiert wie die
gleiche lasertechnologie für den
schnellen dran sind im sonnensystem
verwendet werden könnten wir hoffen
darauf diese technologie bereits in
naher zukunft demonstrieren zu können
statt bis zu neun monate würde eine
reise zum mars damit nur noch knapp 45
tage also anderthalb monate dauern laut
der aktuellen studie bräuchte es
gigantische leser die auf der erde
installiert werden und beweglich sind
mehrere hundert megawatt gläser mit
einem durchmesser von je zehn meter
müssten eingesetzt werden diese könnten
dann gemeinsam aus der ferne den
treibstoff an bord eines raumschiffes im
erd- ob ich entzünden mit einem
gezielten laserstrahl der gemeinsam auf
das raumschiff ab sofort wird und dort
über einen aufblasbaren reflektor
aufgenommen wird dieses kann man sich
ein bisschen so vorstellen wie eine
solaranlagen in der studie ist die rede
von einem laser voll mit proporzsystem
dieser spiegel würde das laserlicht das
ihn von der erde erreicht in richtung
der treibstoff kammer umlenken und
bündeln so käme es letztendlich dazu
dass wasserstoff entzündet und erhitzt
wird das raumschiff ließe sich somit mit
fast 60.000 kilometer pro stunde zum
mars katapultieren sobald das raumschiff
genügend energie aufgenommen hat könnte
der spiegel abgekoppelt werden heißt
also der reflektor könnte recycelt
werden und für weitere missionen genutzt
werden doch problematisch erscheint die
landung des raumschiffs auf dem mars
die kanadischen forscherinnen und
forscher schreiben denn das raumschiff
hat eine viel zu hohe geschwindigkeit es
muss also abgebremst werden um so zu
verhindern dass es auf der oberfläche
des roten planeten zerschellt um zur
landung anzusetzen schlagen die
fachleute einen sogenannten atmosphären
eingang vor dabei würde das raumschiff
durch die atmosphäre geschickt werden
sodass es abgebremst wird um dann in die
umlaufbahn zu gelangen von dort könnte
es in richtung mars oberfläche
weiterreisen das hört sich alles also
ich würde mal sagen ein bisschen
gefährlich an ich bin gespannt nach
ansicht der wissenschaftlerinnen
wissenschaftler wäre das ein extremes
manöver verbunden mit extremen kräften
die dabei auch auf die crew wirken
würden doch die maßnahmen würden das
wohl überstehen so die fachleute es
steht jedenfalls bis wir zum mars reisen
können müssen noch jede menge
technologische und logistische
herausforderung angegangen werden das
sieht auch das kanadische forschungsteam
selbst viele der prozesse die solch eine
mission erfordern würde sind noch längst
nicht praxis erprobt hat so sagt emanuel
play in einem interview mit universe
today die laser heizkörper ist
wahrscheinlich die größte
herausforderung können wir
wasserstoffgas einschließen während es
durch den laserstrahl auf temperaturen
von ärztin tausenden kelvin erhitzt wird
und gleichzeitig die wände der kammer
kühl halten unsere modelle sagen dass
dies machbar ist aber experimentelle
tests empfohlen maßstab sind derzeit
nicht möglich die benötigten 100
megawatt laser sind noch nicht gebaut
worden zum verständnis 10.000 kelvin
entsprechen einer temperatur von rund
9700 grad celsius dennoch auch wenn in
diesen ideen noch viel theorie steckt
und sich die meisten technologien dazu
noch in der entwicklungsphase befinden
das potenzial ist riesig zwei der
größten herausforderung für zukünftige
mars-mission könnten sich damit auf
einen schlag in luft auflösen man denke
da nur an die logistischen und
gesundheitlichen aspekte klar ist
dennoch aber auch dass mars mission
nicht zu beliebigen zeitpunkten starten
könnten im besten fall nur in der zeit
in der sich der rote planet und unsere
erde in ihrer umlaufbahn näher kommen
dann nämlich trennen uns in manchen
fällen sogar nur
56 millionen kilometer im durchschnitt
allerdings beträgt die entfernung vom
mars zur erde
50 millionen kilometer beide distanzen
allerdings ein katzensprung wenn man
sich die maximaldistanz vergegenwärtigt
diese liegt bei etwa 400 millionen
kilometern in den 2000 dreißiger jahren
sollen die ersten bemannten mars-mission
jedenfalls starten sicherlich aber noch
nicht per laser katapult so so wird der
mars zur erde terraforming mit
künstlichen magnetfeld auch ein
gigantisches unterfangen wie das
gelingen soll anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran